من بيروت ينضم الينا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي الياس حندا هجمات متلاحقه من
الجانب الاوكراني على شبه جزيره القرم بدا
يعترف بها الروس هو بالاماكن التي
تستهدفها بشكل واضح
ما الهدف ما الهدف الذي يسعى الاوكرانيون
لتحقيقه في هذه المرحله في القرن
زين هو تعديل تكتيكي عملاني بسبب التعثر
على جبهه الهجوم العكسي الاوكراني الذي
بدا منذ اكثر من شهر ولم يحقق النتائج
اللي كانت مرغوبه او منتظره اليوم انتقلنا
الى تكتيك او عملانيه او استراتيجيه جديده
تقوم على ضرب العمق اللوجستي للقوات
الروسيه عندما نتحدث عن زين كوي هذه
المدينه هي عقدت طرق من سكك الحديد
والطرقات تتجه الطرقات من بعدها شمالا الى
الشمال الشرقي باتجاه زفروجيا والى الشمال
الغربي باتجاه خرسون وهي مستهدفه لانها
عقده طرق وكانت قد استهدفت سابقا عندما
كان فيها صواريخ اسكندر فاذا نحن نتحدث
دائما عن
الحرمان لجيش يستهلك ذخيره وعتاد بشكل
كبير وجيش الروسي نجحت هذه الاستراتيجيه
عندما سحب الجيش الروسي من خرسون بعد
تدمير جسر انطونوف
نعم في المقابل ايضا هناك هجمات الان
بالمسيرات على
موسكوبات الخبر عاديا لا توجد اضرار بليغه
في كل مره ولكن يعني اصبح الامر يتوالى ما
الذي يعنيه ذلك في هذه الحرب
سهام المسيرات لا يمكن ان تحسم الحرب يعني
المسيره على الجبهه لديها مهمه معينه
استطلاع انتحار وبالتالي تصحيح المدفعيه
وحتى عمليه الحرب الالكترونيه هي من ضمن
منظومه قتال معينه لتحقيق هدف عسكري اما
القصف البعيد المدى فهو عمليه اظهار هشاشه
الامن لرئيس بوتين
المعركه لا يمكن لهذه المسيرات ان تصل
يوما ما الى مواقع حساسه في العاصمه
الروسيه
حسب من اين تنطلق سهام اذا انطلقت من
الارض الاوكرانيه شيء المسافه تقدم ب 800
كم اذا انطلقت من الداخل الروسي شيء واذا
انطلقت من البحر شيء اخر فاذا المهم اليوم
هذه الاهداف هذه الاهداف هذه المسيرات
الدقه لهذه المسيرات وبالتالي الحموله
التي يمكن ان تحملها يعني اثنين او
كيلوغرام من المتفجرات ليست كما صواريخ
ستورم شادو على سبيل المثال تقريبا 500
كيلو جرام 500 باوند من المتفجرات يعطي
اثره في العمق الروسي ضمن جزيره القرم
وليس في الداخل الروسي فاذا اعطت نتيجه
سهام عندما قصفت قواعد عسكريه فيها قذيفات
استراتيجيه مثلا قاعده انجلز منها كانت
تنطلق القذفات لضرب الداخل الاوكراني ولكن
هذه المسيرات هي اكثر دعائيه اساسيه فقط
لخلخله مفهوم الامن لدى الرئيس بوتين
وازهار صورته على انه ضعيف ولكنها لن تحسم
المعركه الا اذا كانت على ارض المعركه
الحقيقيه على خط التماس شكرا لك الياس حنا
العميد الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه من